the fastest path for you to get to
success you're after is to model success
the idea here is simple you find people
who have already done the thing that you
want to do learn from them understand
what they did to get there and then try
on their hat right see what worked for
them and apply it to your business this
is what worked for me this is what saved
my company Bill Gates saved my first
company I was struggling I had I'll
start software company that wasn't
making money and I quit
I quit partner and I woke up the next
day and said I need to find a way to
make this happen I can't quit on this
too soon because I'm going to regret it
if I don't keep going and so I said who
has done this before who's done this and
I thought of Bill Gates was the first
person that came to mind was Bill Gates
I looked at his story and how did he
build Microsoft well it was through
Partnerships I started making
Partnerships in my business I had
nothing else to lose I was already at
rock bottom right I already quit on my
partner let's just give this a shot I
landed my first partnership deal for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars and
at the time guys I was making 300 bucks
a month so that money meant the world to
me like that was bank and more important
than that it gave me hope this business
could actually work and it gave me a
model to then go and do it again and
again and again and ever since then
whenever I don't know what to do on
model success I find someone who's done
it and I try to apply their strategies
and make it work for me but this is the
important thing not every strategy is
going to work the same way for them as
it did for you maybe waking up early is
your ticket the best thing you can do is
just go on track you try on their hat
Bill Gates did this Dan Lok does this
Bruce Lee does this awesome try it try
it and see people pray judge so early
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey this is Nina
Carmichael this channel is created to
help you overcome the number one
challenges that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well you
have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something so get ready to know how to
model success match your action to your
Ambitions have a good morning routine
with Evan Carmichael and his top 10
rules for Success enjoy
rule number two match your actions with
your Ambitions your actions have to map
to your Ambitions in a one-off situation
you can always be grateful for what
happened when I broke my neck in
Colorado I'm grateful for the
opportunity I'm the opportunity to learn
to push myself to get better but did it
map to my ambitions right whenever
you're stuck in a one-off situation you
can yes always default to gratitude but
if you get the choice this is the
difference between living in intentional
versus a reactionary life
if you're just grateful for everything
that happens to you and see it as a
journey yes and you've learned yes great
but is it the journey that you want to
be on it's a journey that will get you
to where you want to go because if the
person who wants to hit the town ends up
on the farm
maybe he's not happy maybe that's not
his Ambitions now you might say that
actually served him that is something
that he should have gone down right
every road leads to somewhere but is it
the road that you want to go down do
your actions map to your Ambitions I
think it's really important the guy who
climbed the tree amaze
right his goal was to be there fastest
to take the shortest path that's the
path he should take and yes he was right
and the others were wrong he was right
for him because he wanted to take the
shortest path do your actions map to
your Ambitions you have goals look at
your calendar look at how you're
scheduling your time look at where
you're spending time what you're doing
it on will the actions that you're
taking lead you to accomplish the goals
that you're trying to go after if yes
amazing if not switch things up
I think too often people have hopes and
dreams and desires and Ambitions but
then their schedule doesn't match up you
say you want to do this but when I look
at your calendar it doesn't show me that
you're doing it if you want to have a
YouTube channel show me in your calendar
where you're making YouTube videos for
too many people it's never you're just
not doing it ever
so then it just becomes a hope a dream a
wish a someday
some days not a day of the week right
you got to put it in your calendar make
sure your action is not to your
Ambitions rule number three have a good
morning routine nobody wakes up every
day and says this is gonna be the
greatest day ever not to unlock not Evan
Carmichael not Tony Robbins nobody you
wake up and you're tired and you have
stuff in your eyes and you have lines on
your face from the pillows the
difference between successful people is
that they demand Excellence from
themselves to the habits and routines
that they do daily the problem is that
thinking that these people are different
that if you're not waking up with tons
of motivation ready to take on the day
that something is wrong with you the
only thing that's wrong with you is you
don't have the habits that set you up
for Success every single day and today I
want to change that so I have a 5S
morning routine that I go through every
single day that sets me up for Success
it demands Excellence I'm going to share
with you guys today the first s is sing
the fastest way to change your state is
to put on music the fastest way to go
from feeling low energy tired bored into
an energy of I am ready to go is music
put on the song not that makes you feel
the current way that you're feeling this
is where most people mess up you put on
music for how you're currently feeling
if you're feeling really sad and low
energy you're going to put on really
mellow slow music what does that do it
keeps you in the same state that you're
in
it keeps it keeps exactly where you are
what you want to do is put on the music
for how you want to feel and so I have a
playlist on my main Channel called the
believe playlist which is the songs that
I listen to these are the songs that I
listen to every day they may work for
you they may not work for you there's no
Perfect song for everybody this is a
perfect song for you and so build a
playlist of the songs that make you come
alive here's the criteria if this song
came on it would force you to start
moving if the song came on you find
yourself doing this if the song came on
you would get out of your chair and want
to move around doesn't mean you're gonna
dance like crazy doesn't mean you're
gonna start building out the lyrics that
may be you awesome but if you're a
little more introverted or don't like
the dance something that would make you
move something that would get you at
least in your chair doing this that's
what I want make a playlist and put that
on it's the first thing that you do
every single morning it'll make a huge
difference to setting the tone changing
your state and giving you energy and
momentum to start the day s number two
is Sun I like getting outside I think
there's something about getting outside
of your home of your condo your
apartment getting outside getting in
some fresh air just being out in nature
makes a big difference getting some
getting some vitamins on your face from
the sun outside but also signifying that
you're you're leaving your bedroom
you're leaving the condo the apartment
the home you're leaving what happened
last night and you're ready to go off
and start the day this is especially
important if you're working from home
because it's easy to have your you know
office right next to your bedroom or
maybe your office is your bedroom and
carry that bedroom energy that tired I
just woke up I want to stay in bed I
want to sleep energy into your work and
you won't do great things if that's the
energy you're carrying to your work so
having some kind of ritual that splits
up sleeping energy to I'm ready to go
energy makes a big difference and I find
the easiest way to do it is to get
outside and get some sun bonus points if
you're in a condo apartment to take the
stairs instead of the elevator s number
three is sore and this is the most
important thing for me if you only take
one of the five I think this is the most
important one to take what is the thing
that makes you soar every day what's the
thing that makes you feel alive bold
confident what is that and put it into
your morning routine at some point in
your life you felt bold you felt
Unstoppable you felt confident it's
happened to everybody the problem is you
don't feel that way consistently every
day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man I could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
and you're a different person you're
back to the I don't know if I can do it
I don't know who am I to go do this
crazy thing that's the problem
so whatever the thing is that makes you
feel like you can come alive that gives
you that boldness and confidence planet
with intention every single day into
your morning routine for me what I do is
I record a message on my phone to to
Instagram to my stories to I put it to
LinkedIn and Twitter right now I'm
putting it everywhere but I need to make
a message so I think of somebody that I
helped yesterday
I think of somebody who commented on a
video who I met in person who I coached
on my Instagram live somebody that I
helped yesterday and then I make a
message channeling that person I won't
say the person's name but I have them in
my head I need to remind myself that the
work that I do is important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
hard to imagine that two to three
hundred thousand people watched my
videos yesterday that's crazy it's a
wild number right it's wild it's hard to
like what does it even mean I don't know
I'm just sitting here talking to a
camera in my office and two to three
hundred thousand people are watching my
videos it's crazy I need to think down
to the actual person I need to think
about an individual that this matters to
somebody that the work I do really means
something to them and then I need to
record a message and share that helps me
soar and I do it every day
what is the thing for you what makes you
sore maybe it's watching the 254 series
that I put up every day maybe it's
watching the espresso videos like this
that I put up every day and some people
every day this is part of the morning
routine is watching an espresso video
and I'm humbled to be a part of your
morning routine for other people it
might be meditating they might be
watching a video or might be reading a
book listening to a podcast I don't care
what the thing is but you have felt bold
Unstoppable and confident at some point
in your life what led you to feeling
that way and then demanded of yourself
every day by putting it into your
morning routine the third s is sore it's
the most important one the fourth ass
for me is sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and I want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout a cardio workout a
weights workout I put that into my daily
routine because I want to bust a sweat
and I want to stay healthy into my 40s
which is coming up and then into my 50s
and Beyond and then the last s for me is
scare I want to do something every day
that scares me what I'm doing right now
is to take a cold shower so after
sweating I need to have a shower they
want to show up to work all smelly and
so hop in the shower but right away
start turning the colder and colder and
colder and colder and colder and then
right at the very end I go all the way
cold and I freeze and even just thinking
of it right now
it sucks which is the best right you
want to do the thing that scares you
every day you're teaching yourself that
I do scary things so whatever is scary
for you whether it's taking a cold
shower whether it's making a phone call
whether it's sending an email making a
video and posting it doing scary things
teaching yourself getting that out of
the way reps in the beginning I find
really helps me rule number four be
honest people are afraid to tell the
truth you're afraid to tell the people
are
truth that could actually help them that
could serve them you're afraid to tell
them the truth because you're afraid
that they're going to judge you you're
afraid they're going to reject you
you're afraid they're not going to take
it well you're afraid they're going to
be sensitive but you're actually doing
everybody a disservice and you're gonna
walk away from the conversation team
like I could have helped them I could
have been more valuable to them I could
have saved them for making a really bad
decision a really big mistake all
because you were afraid to tell the
truth whenever I'm meeting somebody I go
to an event I just came back from an
event in Dallas video marketing World
whenever I'm meeting somebody that I
want to learn from I will start off
saying hey man tell me why I suck tell
me why I suck if I'm looking at my
YouTube thumbnails or my titles or me on
camera or any part of something that I
want to improve and work on tell me why
I suck
now why why do that well it's not just
because I'm a glutton for punishment
right I don't want people just yelling
and raging at me it's because when you
do that when you lead with that when you
say tell me why I suck
it gives the other person the permission
to be honest with you
because they have advice that can help
you they have advice that might be able
to change your business or your life but
they're gonna hedge they're gonna play
it safe they're not going to tell you
what you need to hear because they're
afraid of offending you they're afraid
of hurting your feelings and so you open
up and you say tell me that I suck and
why
and then invariably what the answer is
is well you don't suck but you know you
could do this this and that
and they'll tell you what you need to
fix
or otherwise if you didn't lead with the
tell me why I suck they would hedge and
they wouldn't tell you everything that's
on their mind they wouldn't tell you the
thing that you need the most which is
their honest brutal opinion on what you
do now it doesn't mean that you suck as
a human
you're amazing as a human it just means
you don't have the skill set you're not
good at this one thing that this person
is an expert at and can help you
and so the next time you're going to an
event or you're talking to somebody who
might be able to help you lead with it
lead to say I love I respect you I love
what you do I'm trying to work on this
tell me why I suck
and then watch the honesty come through
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five showed up people
don't show up for one of three reasons
number one is you're afraid you're
afraid of rejection you're afraid of
failure you're afraid of it not working
out and so you just don't show up number
two is you're not consistent you show up
some days but you don't show up other
days because you don't have the routines
and habits in place to make you show up
consistently every single day and number
three is you don't want to you don't
want to show up because you don't
actually enjoy the thing that you're
about to do you would rather
procrastinate on it because you don't
love it and showing up is more painful
than just sitting around so my goal
today with this video is to help you
bust through these so that you can show
for life
so I think
the showing up is actually a good thing
it means that you are doing something
different something outside your comfort
zone something that is that is not
normal that is new and that's good you
want to be pushing the envelope if there
was nothing that you are afraid to show
up to today tomorrow next week then
you're not growing you're not learning
you're not pushing against your
boundaries and comfort zones and so even
today I had to show up and and again it
should be every single day so today I
was procrastinating on sending out an
email to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel more cross pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I email Grant and
emailed for the people with a new idea
that I had so when the idea was first
suggested to me about doing this and
reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay it's gonna require an
ask I might get rejected it may not work
out and I had it scheduled for today
because today was my YouTube day and so
I look at the list today I'm like ah
maybe I should start with one person or
two people or just pick the easy people
and just the fact that I felt that just
the fact that that was one of the
reasons meant I had to go and do five I
had to do a bigger number I had to go
after the harder people I had to do the
people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
going to care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it I have
just to show myself because the worst
thing you can do is get to the edge of
the cliff and say you're gonna jump and
then not jump It's better not to catch
that you're nervous it's better not to
even come up with the idea to just float
around in ignorance ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it I've trained
myself I want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid rule
number six Focus the problem isn't that
you're not a genius that you're not
talented that you don't have wisdom and
abilities and resourcefulness and that
you're not Michael Jordan that's not the
problem the problem is you're not
focused you're not doing the things that
you need to do I just came back from
video marketing World in Dallas and I
was being asked about where to spend the
time Which social media sites to spend
time on and I think this is a classic
example of where entrepreneurs fail is
you're trying to do everything and as a
result you suck everywhere and feel
burnt out tapped out and not building
momentum if you get to the end of a week
and you feel like you worked your face
off but you look back what did I get
done if that's how you're ending a week
you worked hard and feel like what did I
get done you're not focused you're
switching between tasks too much
instead of having all of these social
media sites at the same time pick one
and crush it
I quoted Andrew Carnegie at my event and
my speech my favorite quote from him is
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket everybody's saying
diversify diversify diversify have 18
different multiple streams of income
look at the people who are who are a
one-person show with 18 streams of
income they're making no money
you're making ten dollars a month from
this and 25 a month from that and 18
cents from this you're not making money
now as you build and scale and grow and
you have a team like I do I've got 24
people on my team okay great now it
might be time to diversify but as a solo
person you can't do everything yourself
and you are a genius you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something and
that's what you need to find and that's
where you need to spend as much time as
possible on until you're making money
you can invest back into your business
and continue to grow rule number seven
love what you do this is why it's so
important that you love what you do it's
why it's the number one rule for Success
that comes up over and over and over and
over again is people love what they do
the people who are winning at the
highest level they love what they do
that allows them to be relentless
because you can talk about being
relentless and giving it all you've got
and going all in and grinding and giving
110 percent
but if you don't love it you're gonna
quit it may not be after a day may not
be after a month may not be after a year
but you're gonna quit when it gets too
hard and you don't love it you will quit
this is why so many entrepreneurs fail
because you're just chasing an
opportunity you're just looking at the
fastest way to make a buck in 2019 in
2020 and 2021 the fastest way to make
some money you're gonna give up
unless you love it now money is
important it's got to be in your top
five but it's not number one
it can't be number one if money is your
number one you're gonna fail you just
won't put in the work the people who win
have something that they put above money
and that's what allows them to wake up
and be relentless and put in the work
you're looking at a guy here who sucked
at making videos you can go back to my
channel you can watch the First videos I
was nervous I was shy uh I still am an
introvert but it's through practice
through being relentless I've had my
channel for 10 years I've made five or
six thousand videos across my four
more than four now nine or so channels
five or six thousand videos that's crazy
right that's crazy who does that you
have to love it it doesn't feel like
work making these videos is fun for me
still 10 years later is still fun for me
I'm excited the second that it gets to
be oh I gotta make videos that's it I'm
out because the people who love doing it
will crush me I was looking at my
YouTube thumbnail uh examples I'm doing
a YouTube course right now where I'm
teaching people how to have success on
YouTube how to get your first million
subscribers get where is it get get get
there that gold button get one of those
for you write your thought leader you're
an expert I want you to get a million
subscribers that's that's the course
that I'm launching right now so I'm
looking at my thumbnail experiments
I have a 130 thumbnail experiments
happening right now on my channel I'm
testing 130 different variations then I
want to complete it and what what we've
completed and gone through 1100
something completed thumbnail
experiments just on thumbnails just
testing my thumbnails we've done over
1100 different experiments that's crazy
right testing big changes like not
having text on a thumbnail and making it
purple and crazy colors to really little
tiny changes like what if we just tweak
this person's eyes what if we alter the
shade of orange just little tiny changes
that most of you probably never notice
why
I love it
I can't help it
I loved I wake up when I think about
this stuff and that's what I want for
you
that's what you need to be doing and it
can't be forced Jerry Seinfeld calls it
the torture that you can endure the
torture that you can endure most people
talk about passion and purpose which is
great
but it it's torture for other people
rule number eight change your
environment I think everyone is born an
optimist and then your environment sucks
the soul out of most people when you're
a baby you don't stress out about how
you look what you're wearing or how
you're smelling when you're a kid you
don't hate your life and complain about
the world if there's negativity in your
head it was put there by someone and if
you want to change it you need to change
your environment so I've had the good
pleasure of seeing one of my friends
Mark Drager a great friend of the
channel been involved with the channel
for a number of years become more
optimistic become more positive and he
was wondering could I even do it is it
possible he was a guy who was naturally
naturally pessimistic he had a lot of
stuff happen to him like we all have a
lot of situations a lot of circumstances
that made him see the the negative of
what's Happening of be pessimistic of
not being the typical
optimistic everything's gonna work out
great entrepreneur and so what changed
over the past 12 months he's made a
significant investment in himself I've
been hanging around with him a lot more
we've co-hosted a podcast together he's
hanging around me my content gay reviews
content Tom Billy's content more he's
been the Tony Robbins seminar twice in
the past year brought his team with him
and he's slowly inching towards more
optimism more positivity that more
things are possible
because of the negative upbringing that
he had it takes a lot of unwiring it
takes a lot of shift in your focus it
takes a lot of with purpose with intent
changing your environment changing the
people you hang out with changing where
you the physical environment that you're
in
to make a change I went to Mark's office
and he's moving his office he's created
his own office he's putting a picture on
the wall of himself and then what he
wants to be as as positive inspiration
every day he's looking at what kind of
colors and what kind of furnishings and
and what kind of the core can I have in
my office to make me feel bold to make
me feel alive every single day
it's possible and I think that's the
starting point for a lot of people it's
possible to change your outlook it's
possible to become more optimistic that
negativity that was planted in your head
was put there by somebody else who hates
their life you were not born to wake up
and hate your life you were not born to
wake up and think that it's just
negativity all around the world you're
not born to wake up and be a pessimist
you're not it was put there by somebody
somebody else who hated their life and
we need to eject that person we need to
unwire the years or Decades of training
and in that void you replace it with the
thing that you want if you want more
optimism you you surround yourself with
the most optimistic people you can find
in person on your team in video format
in the books you read in the clubs
you're hanging out with your first limit
access from the negative people
limit exposure you may not be able to
completely wipe them out like maybe
they're your parents but you can limit
exposure you can limit access either
with time or just topics that you're
covering and then inject more positivity
optimism to the people books resources
environment that you have around you
rule number nine make proper decisions
you need to make the big decisions in
your life with your heart and the small
ones with your head this is where so
many entrepreneurs fall down this is
where so many entrepreneurs make
mistakes because you see a trend you see
an opportunity you see something that
makes sense it just makes sense on paper
it's so clear this is gonna happen but
if it doesn't energize you if you don't
love it if it's not in your heart to
statement I can't wait to go off and do
that thing you're never gonna win you're
never gonna win because you're going up
against people who love it you're going
up against people who love it who
breathe it who sleep it who dream about
it and for you it's just an opportunity
you're never going to win big look at
all your Heroes all your mentors people
you look up to the people who've done it
it's like I want to be like this part
person in my field I want to be I want
to do it like she did it like she did it
they love doing the thing they love
doing the thing doing it gives them
energy
I look at what I do I'm here in Dallas
I'm about to speak at video marketing
World an annual Summit of some of the
top creators on YouTube to help share
give back help the community give
feedback Train on YouTube I love doing
this stuff
filming videos for you guys not because
it's a strategy not because I need to
make a video a day because I love it
this this is this is the best I'm about
to go into this meeting to this
conference and I'm going to hang out
with entrepreneurs all day long from the
time I get in there until whatever time
am I'm going to be hanging out with
entrepreneurs and helping them with
their business helping them with their
Channel because I love it
and if that sounds exhausting for you
amazing don't do it and if it sounds
energizing for you yes go and do it you
need to make the big decisions with your
heart and then your head's still
important it's like don't listen it's
not the message is not don't listen to
Logic the message is not don't look for
opportunities it's look for
opportunities within the thing that you
love
right if if I love making videos and I
love making content and I love helping
entrepreneurs but I went all in on
MySpace right now I'm gonna lose it's
not the right strategy right you need
both it's working hard plus working
smart it's following what you love doing
plus chasing opportunities but what
takes precedence what's the most
important thing your heart the energy if
you are saying oh man Monday if that's
your mindset around Monday you're doing
the wrong thing you're in the wrong
career you're in the wrong business you
will never be the top player in your
industry it'll never happen for you if
that's your mindset
if you're itching to get back to it if
you can't wait to go to that meeting
can't wait to code can't wait to make
that piece of art can't wait to go and
make that video can't wait to sit down
and write lyrics for your next song if
that's the thing
then you're gonna be successful it's not
going to be easy it's still the long
road it's still a path you still have to
put in the grind and the effort and use
strategies to help you get there faster
but it has to start by doing things that
are energizing to you you're going to
spend so much time working guys you're
gonna spend so much time working as an
entrepreneur
why not do stuff that makes you come
alive why not do stuff that gives you
energy
and so I want you to get out of your
head I want you to stop making decisions
first from your head I want you to stop
making decisions only because it's going
to help you get some goal
a short-term thinking and you're never
going to win doing it big decisions with
the heart big decisions that give you
energy look at your calendar are you
energized about the week that's coming
up look at your account go load your
calendar right now load it on your
computer a little on your phone however
you learn you can't look at it look at
your calendar look at the week ahead are
you excited
are you excited about what you're about
to do if not you're doing the wrong
stuff
if you're only excited about 10 of your
calendar
you're only pouring your Genius your
Michael Jordan level Talent into 10 of
your time you're not gonna get to where
you want to go you need to flip it
even if it doesn't make practical sense
at the beginning
because all great things are made from
the heart all great things every great
business every great song every great
creation
started from here from a place of
passion from place of purpose from place
of energy
and I want to put some pressure on you
guys to go off and Chase it down because
so many entrepreneurs fail
and they lose a lot of money
it's not
an easy game but one of the biggest
reasons if not the number one reason is
because people picking in the street
people pick a business idea solely
because they're chasing an opportunity
down and they didn't love doing the work
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip on try things
there's a reason why in my videos I say
you have Michael Jordan level talent I
believe it it's true you you have
Michael Jordan level talented something
you are the best the absolute best add
something in the world
most people either one don't believe it
they don't believe that their world
class has something or two they found
the thing that they could be world class
at but they don't have enough guts to
chase it down they don't believe in
themselves enough to chase them down
here's the thing
you need to First explore you need to
explore you gotta search you got to say
yes you got to try things you don't know
that that Tim Hortons is your favorite
coffee cup until you've tried it right
you don't know that Sushi is your
favorite food until you've tried it
Sushi doesn't make sense
right this is how we think our logical
brain starts to analyze things and
because it doesn't make sense we don't
try it Sushi doesn't make sense you're
gonna take raw fish mix it with rice put
seaweed around it and then eat it that
sounds nasty right if you've never tried
it before it sounds nasty but best
a lot of the things that you might be
great at you are a judge and you are
dismissing because it doesn't make
logical sense you don't need to wrap
your head around it you need to wrap
your heart around it you have to feel it
you have to say yes and be willing to
try at least once if you don't know what
you're great at you have to say yes and
try things and you pay attention to the
feeling
the most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it I expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right expect
to suck at the beginning you're gonna
suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again
as an introvert Making Connections
always seemed incredibly scary to me I
hate going to networking events I'm not
life of a party I don't know uh how to
approach people and ask them questions
and it always just felt I think at the
end of the day very fake and inauthentic
and just not me you know I don't know
how to introduce myself and I don't know
I don't know what to talk about I want
to sit here and talk I'm here in Arizona
and it's beautiful and it's sunny and
it's amazing but I don't I don't I don't
want to just talk about the weather you
know I don't want to talk about boring
superficial stuff and
it took me a long time to get
comfortable coming to events and I'm
this is actually a great moment because
I'm here at genius Network
um it's a I just came out of a two-day
event where people are paying 25 000 to
be a part of and the next two days uh
it's another event where they're paying
a hundred thousand dollars to be part of
and I'm a guest here speaking at um at
both events and I would have I would
have never like younger Evan would have
never come to something like this
because
not that it's not valuable just I would
have been too afraid to to network and
to uh to ask for help and to introduce
myself and all of those things what I've
discovered if you're an introvert
what I've discovered is that introverts
are great listeners
and we care
and you can be a fantastic networker if
you're an introvert but your goal is not
to know the entire room and the goal is
not to run into the the event and say
look at me here's what I do and where
the shiniest suit and be be the
loudmouth if that's you awesome roll
with it but if it's not your goal is to
just connect with a few people on a
really meaningful level
I've connected over the past couple days
with some amazing people who've given me
some amazing advice and connections and
experiences and
just amazing people but it hasn't been I
don't there's lots of people who I
haven't connected with
you know there were maybe
50 people here over the past two days
and in the bigger the more expensive
group I think there's 30 people or 20
people coming and I probably won't get
to talk to everybody
um probably not I mean maybe
but I'm not I'm not I'm not judging
myself for not knowing everybody I'm not
judging myself for
how many business cards I leave with
though I don't the people you still use
business cards I don't have any business
cards I'm not judging myself if I
connected with them or not it's more I'd
rather spend
time with a few people
who I can connect with on some kind of
level and
that ends up leading to so much better
things Joe polich is the guy who runs
this so this is his office and he's the
one put puts his events together and
he's he's known as the most connected
man in the world right some of his bios
and websites will say people talk about
him he's the most connected man in the
world in hanging around him
for the past few days I can understand
why so if we're going to reverse
engineer
Joe polished his success and he'll he'll
say that he's you know on the
introverted side
he's invited me to his home
he's I came in a couple days early and
helped him with his team and His Channel
and he invited me to stay at his home
today is our day off in between the two
events and he's invited me to go work
out with him and go do some IVs with
vitamins in it and go sit in a hot sauna
then then jump in a nice cold bath and
ask me how I'm doing and what I'm up to
and if I need if I need anything or if I
want to use his office I mean I'm using
I'm using his office I guess the outside
the film today it's too beautiful today
not to film outside but but whatever I
need he doesn't just do that for anybody
you know he's not just going to open up
his home for anybody
and he's really trying to spend time
think about me if I would do that I'm
thinking man probably not and so that's
that's maybe a learning for me because
I've run events I've hosted my own
events and they usually just knock me
out when I when I posted my thought
Leadership Academy in Toronto it would
knock me out I mean the last day of one
of the um
the last day of my event I remember I I
passed out like I had a break of 15
minutes and I I passed out and fell
asleep on a floor like on my dance floor
because I was giving so much and then my
my body gave out on me
and so I couldn't imagine then also like
Joe's got such a crazy week think about
how much people are paying him right
they pay him 25 000 for
the event that just finished and then a
hundred thousand dollars for the event
that's coming up
you gotta deliver some value right if
people are coming and they're paying a
hundred thousand dollars to be here that
that's
gotta be at least for me incredibly
stressful to do that and while he's in
the middle of all of that he's worried
about me and how I'm doing and if I want
to stay with him and if I need to if I
want to go do some vitamin IVs and if
I'm being looked after if I need an
internet connection or a place to work
and the amount of text that he sent
while he's
in the sauna or working out or
doing his meetings
I said how are you still thinking about
me you've got you've got so much going
on I I don't I mean it's something that
that I'm honestly inspired by and I find
aspirational
but he does it so well
and it's like he can't do that for
everybody and so uh you know I'm
grateful I guess that he saw something
in me that he'd want to spend that kind
of time with
but he's very selective over who he
brings in and then once you're in he's
he's
going to be the greatest resource of all
time
and I think that's how you win
ultimately at least for me I think it's
a fantastic model for me to learn from
and keep trying to do better at and that
how can you win as an introvert when you
are networking
and trying to help people
introverts are great listeners
introverts care we want to help we want
to serve and we can't do it for
everybody because we let too many people
in we then we have no energy for
ourselves
and recognize that that's how you you
that's your secret superpower
that's your superpower
your superpower my superpower is to find
just a few people
at every place you go to your goal is
not to meet the whole event it's made a
few people
and figure out how you can help them and
genuinely help them like generally serve
them not not just if I help them do this
and they're gonna help me do that right
we're not don't don't approach it as a
transaction I think introverts are great
at this right it's not a transaction you
we value relationships
but are too afraid to go up and say hi
to people and don't like the The Fluffy
talk
so just make it a goal to find a few
people
and be of service and great things
happen
one of the things I've taken away and
just reinforced from the past couple
days is great things happen to me
and I'm I'm actually becoming less of a
gold person like where do you want to be
next year I have no idea because great
things happen to me
because if you keep pouring into other
people and keep bringing value and keep
helping
great things will happen to you that you
you never thought of
you know that you never thought would
exist and yet here they are now showing
up in your life
and so a challenge for you would be to
think about
whether it's the next event you're going
to or even just some people in your
network
like who do you already know
who are good people
be in the business of collecting good
people like who do you already know
who's a good person who you
you want to serve and help on a deeper
level
and just find a way to reach out and
help them
be of service
I make a list of of the top kind of 100
people that I want to stay in touch with
because I'll forget I'll forget to stay
in touch I'm too present-minded Focus
but if I haven't stayed in touch with
them in the past 90 days I'll find some
some way to help whether it's sharing
something on social whether it's making
a video giving them some YouTube advice
just just connecting asking how it can
be a resource
I schedule in the ongoing connection
because
these people have helped me a lot and I
want to continue to help them and if
you're just going strategy you know
continue to help successful people will
lead to you having more success because
it will they will find ways to come back
and help you you're almost guilting them
to do it even better is to not even be
as strategic about it
just by putting out good energy just by
serving others just by using that good
karma it comes
and in the process of giving if you can
remind yourself the great things happen
to you
that if I just keep showing up and
serving and helping and doing my very
best every day
great things will happen to me great
things will happen to you great things
will happen to you you just have to keep
going get rid of your 10-year goals and
create a mission instead I think a lot
of people are so worried about where
they're going to be in a year and five
years and 10 years we do these goals
planning actually you ever gone through
that you ever gone through a goal
planning exercise goal said and exercise
at events you read a book says we're
going to be in a year and five years or
ten years
and the more that I've thought about it
the more that I've gone through the
exercise is the more I realized it's not
important
that's not helpful it's not where we
want to be because you don't know what
you're capable of in a five-year period
a 10-year period think about who you
were five years ago take today's date
and subtract five years think about that
person
could you have predicted where you are
right now could the person you were five
years ago have any degree of confidence
is plan a life for who you are right now
it's like there's no way there's no way
not if you're growing not if you're
learning not if you're improving if
you're watching this channel then you're
somebody who is learning and growing and
improving and so you had no idea what
you're capable of five years ago and so
what makes you think that it's any
different now that you can plan for the
next five years the only way that you
can create a 10-year plan for yourself
is if you are not growing and you're in
a really static life you know like if
you're going to be a lawyer and you're
going to work your way up and be a
senior partner at the law firm and that
that takes a certain amount of time cool
you could you could plan that out
that's a pretty boring life
you know chances are if you're watching
this video you don't want that life that
you want to create new and build new and
that requires
being the being flexible to jump off of
your 10-year goals right it's not that
it's wrong to have goals goals can work
they can be motivating but
your goals right now a reflection of who
you currently are
that's the problem whatever goal you set
right now is a reflection of who you
currently are and the more that you are
growing as a human and the more that the
world involves and new technology comes
out and New Opportunities arise
the longer Horizon you put out the less
accurate it's going to be
and so instead of worrying about having
a 10-year goal replace it with a mission
the problem of a 10-year goal is you
could actually hit your 10-year goal
it's just way small compared to what
you're capable of
and so the answer is have a mission
what's your mission what are you trying
to accomplish like what's the big
problem that you're trying to solve and
then wake up every day trying to attack
that mission as opposed to worrying
about where you're going to be in 10
years this might flip a lot of goal
setting on its head that might flip a
lot of what you've been told or taught
or thought on its head and listen if
having that 10-year goal works for you
and is actually motivating cool keep
keep with it keep going if it's helping
you use it but if you feel like there's
something more or you feel like 10 year
goal is not enough you don't feel
motivated when you look at your 10-year
goal from two years ago it doesn't
appeal to you anymore it's probably why
you know you're you're growing too
quickly the problem is not your goals
the problems that you grew too much the
10-year goal is great for who you were
three years ago
you're not that person anymore you've
grown too much it's that's that's not a
reason to feel bad that's really feeling
amazing you know you've grown you've
outgrown yourself you've shed your skin
you now turn into the next generation of
you
and So my answer is admission what's the
mission what are you trying to
accomplish you know so for me I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
entrepreneurs and you know people don't
believe in themselves people don't
believe in themselves and I don't
believe myself enough you don't believe
in yourself enough nobody nobody you
know walking out here believes in
themselves enough we just we don't
believe in ourselves enough
and I want to I want to solve that
problem and I'm I'm never going to solve
that problem and I wake up every day
trying to solve that problem and why
it's so helpful to have a mission like
that is
because it gives you something to fight
for every day and there's always
something new that can come out that can
help you with that and there's always
opportunities that I think guys the
amount of things that I've seen and that
happened in the past 10 years if you
look at 10 years ago
where was I on YouTube I started in
April 2009 so it was early in on my
career on YouTube I had a couple hundred
subscribers there's no way I would have
said it'd be here
there's no way just with the with the
impact I've had with the people I've met
with the even just the confidence to sit
here guys I would have been so terrified
to sit in a park making a video
terrified of who's watching me who's
judging me who's coming around the
corner who's behind there maybe you know
looking at me and judging me you know it
would have been impossible so the person
I was 10 years ago would have never even
thought of this as a possibility
and now it's it's it's normal
it's not a problem
right how quickly that we can grow
and so you can with a mission it's a
problem you're trying to solve and then
as you develop new skill sets and
improve mindsets and better belief
systems and as you know the mark and the
technology evolves and opportunities
arise as you keep going and building
momentum there will be new things that
you can go off and do that you never
thought were possible but it's always in
service of the mission
so how do you find the mission well
that's your purpose for me and your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled the most with is the thing
you want to help other people through
and so I struggled so much to believe in
myself in the early days of my business
and quit like I quit for one day on my
business in worst day of my life and I
just want to make the path a little bit
easier for others how do I keep going
people ask me how do you how do you keep
going how do you keep making content
have you made I don't know thirteen
thousand fifteen thousand I don't know
how many videos I've made it's crazy how
many videos we've done
I only slept two and a half hours last
night it was a really rough night why
get up and keep making content because
I'm on a mission
because this means something to me
whether four people watch this video or
four million people watch this video
I'm hoping that
this video in some way is a video that
moves a needle just a little bit for
somebody watching maybe it's you maybe
this is the video they decide I'm gonna
I'm gonna do something I'm gonna find my
mission I'm gonna stop creating 10-year
goals and stop over planning over
preparing and overthinking and over
strategizing and over doubting myself
and just go do something like maybe
today this is the video or maybe I make
another video today that accomplishes
that like that's that's my goal that's
why I do what I do that's what gives me
the energy to wake up when every bone in
my body is saying you know sleep don't
do the difficult thing
and it's easy because I'm on a mission
and so what's yours what did you
struggle with the most as a human
and if you can connect to that
you think about all the people who
currently are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with
you know you're not done growing you're
not done learning you're still improving
there's still a long ways to go you're
by no means perfect neither am I
but you're a lot further ahead than you
used to be and there's a lot of people
right now who are right now stuck where
you used to be
I didn't know what to do they don't know
where to turn they don't have anybody
who believes in them they don't have any
hope they don't have any strategies they
think they're stocked they think they're
stuck
in your story your message your content
you reaching out you could make the
difference for them
if you actually believe that it's going
to just change the energy with which you
show up and open you up to amazing new
opportunities that again you can't
predict 10 years in advance
so it's a it's a challenge it's a call
to action today
if you love setting your 10-year goals
and it works for you amazing keep going
do what works for you but if you feel
like
you're judging yourself against them if
you feel like they're not working for
you if you feel like you're six months
in and you already want to change it the
problem is not that it's a 10-year goal
the problem is that you have already
outgrown what what you're capable of
you've already outgrown it six months in
a year and
and the thing that you want to outgrow
is the mission
to have a have a goal have a purpose so
big
that you never solve it and you wake up
every day trying to solve it standing up
has changed my life not
for myself and standing up for what I
might believe in and the the standing up
what is it it's not metaphysical the the
the theoretical I don't know but but
actually standing up like the physical
standing up
going from sitting down like I am right
now in my car but to standing up has
changed my life stand-up desks are now a
huge uh Trend and a huge boost and I
would definitely recommend checking some
of those out but when I first started
setting up was probably
wow I don't know maybe 20 years ago 15
years ago
I just found that when I was on the
phone and talking this is how it started
so I've been on I'm actually now on a my
office is a trampoline so I'm on a
stand-up trampoline desk I had to raise
my desk uh 10 inches so that the
trampoline could be underneath it and I
get 20 to 40 000 jumps a day on my
trampoline and went through three
trampolines last year because they broke
because most are not designed to be
jumped on that often but
trampolining while working might be a a
stretch for most people right now if you
ever see me and I'm doing an interview
and I'm on my main computer you might
see me
doing little micro bounces and I'm
trying to control it like hold it onto
the desk like don't bounce don't bounce
don't bounce because it can be it can be
annoying to watch on an interview but
for the most time I'm bouncing up and
down all day long on my trampoline now
why why did I start this well
15 20 years ago I just found it when I
was on the phone
and I was I was talking to clients I
would be better when I was walking
around
I don't know if it's a nervous energy or
what but when I sat down it was less
energetic less less like let's go do
this thing and when I when I stood up it
was just I had more energy
you test yourself do you have more
energy when you're standing up or when
you're sitting down and so on calls I
would I would not just stand up but I
would walk around I like to have
something going on I often people
comment on some of my videos where I
pitch it with my ring so my ring
whenever I'm thinking I like to be
I don't like to be meditative and still
I like to have something going on so I'm
often I'm often fidgeting with my ring
or you might see my ears move up and
down every now and then when I'm
thinking
um I like walking around just having
something go and it helps me think and
process better
and so that was the starting point was
just okay cordless phone and walk around
then I discovered a stand-up desk I
forget who it was it might have been Tim
Ferriss again way back in the day and
the the test was not a full-on standard
desk because those barely existed but I
took my bookcase
and I cleared off the book with all the
books in the bookcase and I found the
shelf that was the kind of the best
height to put my laptop on and I just
tried standing there and I think this is
a good life hack not just for standing
up or not but just in general if you
want to try something
don't go off and buy the most expensive
thing and wait three weeks for it to be
delivered just go try something right
now
so if you want to try stand-up desks
don't go buy a stand-up desk don't do
that that's the worst thing you can do
don't spend a ton of money on a stand-up
desk and then wait three weeks for to be
delivered to you
just take a bookcase or take some boxes
and put it at the right height and see
how it feels
you want to start a YouTube channel
perfect don't don't go researching and
spend weeks buying the gear and the
lights and the cameras and all that
stuff and it most of that most of the
stuff in these little experiments end up
failing and they now you bought all this
gear that's just sitting in your garage
you know your closet or your mom's
basement
the best thing to do is just start find
a small way to just get started and so
I stood up at my bookcase and the first
day I didn't last very long 20 minutes
40 minutes I it didn't last very long
when you're not used to standing up it
it's really hard it's like oh where I
need to sit down and after that first 20
or 40 minutes I got tired and I had to
sit down because my body wasn't used to
it but while I was standing up like I
really like this this is cool I have
more energy in just answering emails and
whatever else I was doing at the time I
had more energy so I'm gonna try it
again and that 20 minutes became 30
minutes between 40 became two hours
became four hours became six hours to
the point was like I could just stand up
all day long it became weird when people
came over to my office because there
were no chairs to sit down at so when
we're doing a meeting I'm standing up
and so they were standing up because
there were no chairs and it felt awkward
to have one person standing one person
sitting and then they start getting
tired because after 20 minutes of
standing up we got tired so I had to I
had to bring chairs back to my office to
host meetings and
um but that was the process that was the
starting point and it it turned out to
have all sorts of positive health
benefits and I had I had
foot issues I had uh the things that you
put in your in your shoes what they're
called not implants uh customized Souls
whatever I was going to a car like in my
20s I was going to chiropractor almost
every week because my back was was a
mess my knees were were achy and
cracking every time I was walking like
my body seemed to be falling apart in my
20s I'm now 42 in May I'm 42 and my body
is in better condition than I was in my
20s
because a big I think a big factor is
because I'm on a trampoline all day long
instead of sitting all day long with
terrible posture and my body falling
apart now I'm jumping on the trampoline
all day long it's easy on my joints my
body I'm happy I have more energy and as
a result I'm healthier
the move to a trampoline came because I
was I was already standing up for
at least five years
uh maybe more and I saw Tony Robbins do
uh his his seminars and uh
backstage he would always jump before he
goes on stage Tony jumps a couple times
on his rebounder rebounder is just a
mini trampoline not like the giant
trampolines like what you have in your
backyard or rebounder is a mini version
of it that you can keep in your office
or your home or whatever he jumps a
couple times on his rebounder uh sprays
something in his mouth uh does like a
spin and then walks on stage
if you ever see him backstage that's
what he's always doing he jumps on his
trampoline a couple times puts something
in his mouth spins around goes out on
stage ready to go alright so that's
pretty cool I wonder what he's spraying
in his mouth uh and I like the whole
trampoline thing if I'm already standing
up why not get a trampoline and try and
so again what's what's the easiest way
to go off and do it well I I went to my
local Walmart and I bought a rebounder
and brought it home and
had to adjust the height of my desk and
had to raise it beyond what the max
height was and the rebounder I bought
ended up breaking shortly after because
it wasn't designed to be jumped on that
often all day long every day right but
whatever it's fine Lessons Learned right
you figure it out you think do is this
worth doing or not
take the idea that you've got and try
because again the biggest thing that
most people are missing is just momentum
you're just not trying you have this
you've got this idea and we spend our
best energy planning and ideating and
researching and what's the perfect
trampoline and what's the perfect
stand-up desk and you spend all that
energy researching and then tomorrow you
wake up the next week you come back or
the next month or whatever like nothing
has happened on it still
if all these great intentions but it's
not enough momentum
and so idea to action trust that your
ideas come to you for a reason and go do
something about them
and so go get the stand-up desk by
creating boxes in your office
you know go get the cheapest trampoline
at Walmart and just jump on it and see
how it feels
it's ended up changing my life so
I'm not used to sitting down anymore uh
we actually moved we just sold our place
we bought a new place and I moved into
one of the rooms as a temporary place
where we were showing our place because
my office backdrop doesn't is not very
conducive to selling the house most
people are not used to a stand-up desk a
giant stand-up desk and trampoline and
all that and so I took my office down
because when you're selling a home you
wanted to appeal to
everybody
and
I sat down for I don't know a couple
weeks while we were selling our place
and all of a sudden the back issues came
back I was cracking my back a lot my
knees started to hurt again my feet
started to hurt again my posture was
terrible again and I realized wow this
is why I stand up
so two lessons in this video the first
is try standing up
yeah you'll probably have more energy
you'll probably feel better it's
probably better for your health people
say sitting is the new smoking right so
try standing up and just give it a shot
and don't stress out if you get tired
after 20 minutes like I did the first
time through it's okay but do you have
more energy while you're working while
you're standing up and if so then just
keep going and just start with a
bookshelf for some bookshelves or some
boxes whatever just to get started and
the second lesson is is just do
something just momentum imperfect action
the ideas that you have in your head are
great they're genius you need to do
something you need to stop putting the
gas pedal on the energy that's flowing
through you like greatness is flowing
through you you're actively saying stop
stop stop do something find the smallest
possible way today today like right now
the smallest possible way take that
awesome idea in your head and build some
momentum towards it
the only thing you're missing towards
your great life is the momentum think
big act small think big you got a big
dream a big goal a big mission some big
thing that you want to get done that's
where we love being as entrepreneurs
right we love thinking about the big
future and what we could build and it is
amazing and exciting but it can also be
overwhelming it can be stressful it can
be hurtful to our own self-esteem
because
tell me if this happened to you you've
got this big idea and big goal
and it's exciting to think about it but
then it also becomes scary and it
becomes impossible and it becomes
something that someone like you can't do
and then we get overwhelmed by the
details and then we can't
do anything about it because it feels
too big and to execute it we need a team
or we need venture capital and we need
investors and we need better people
around us and we need more skills and
all of these doubts and insecurities
creep in does that sound familiar is
that you
certainly is me
you know I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough
and anytime I think even close to that
scale it's instantly well how am I going
to do that how am I going to do that I
know we're close
and so the thing that's really helped me
is think big but then act small
because the biggest thing that most
people are missing I'm missing you're
missing is just momentum biggest thing
we're missing is just we're not we're
not doing enough because thinking big
and having a big idea is amazing but
that alone is not enough you have to go
and you got to do the work and we're so
worried about the work being perfect
right you're so worried about the first
thing being amazing
and it won't be
and this is a hard lesson that I learned
when I was uh in my early 20s in my
first business and we lost a 40 million
dollar deal because I was trying to be
perfect
and I spent the whole summer working on
this perfect plane
and I lost the deal and I'm I'm a
recovering perfectionist and I think
seeing your perfectionist really just
means you're afraid right you're afraid
of it not being good enough you're
afraid of launching something and people
seeing it and judging you or you're
afraid of launching it and then not seen
it nobody caring right we're afraid of
being seen and not being seen both at
the same time we're afraid has the
answers to do something immediate action
I've been helping people in my movement
makers program
get going on YouTube and now on Tick
Tock and the amount of indecision that
people have around creating their first
video
right what should I wear what should I
say what should I open the line be what
should my thumbnail be what kind of gear
should I use what kind of camera what
kind of microphone what kind of
fill in the blank right all the things
that just prevent you from taking action
where the answer is just film honestly
like just just get something up look I'm
filming this video on my phone walking
down the street
I didn't sleep that well last night
and uh getting some sunshine on my face
and just press and record and going
and I'm doing the best I can with what I
have and that's what you need to do is
just get it started because best plan
that you can come up with right now
is nowhere close to the plan that will
help you win
you know the plan that you come up with
right now is not going to be the one
that works because you don't have all
the information and so the idea that you
can plan
what the end looks like and the path to
get there is impossible so we spend our
best energy
planning and thinking instead of
actually doing
that's a big problem
and so it starts with okay you've got
this big idea awesome now what are you
going to do today about it today there's
a couple of hacks that I want to share
with you and I think can help so the
first is the two percent difference and
the two percent difference says instead
of planning for a hundred percent you
work on the first two percent so what is
that first superset that's all you need
to work on what's the first two percent
so if you're thinking about YouTube or
making a tick tock if you're thinking
about a health Journey you're thinking
about
whatever it is for your business that
you want to launch what's the first two
percent
and just start building momentum so you
know if you want to make a YouTube video
go film a video just take out your phone
and film a video just like I am right
now do you want to get started on Tick
Tock cool same thing
flip your flip your phone the other way
vertical and start making your video you
want to start a health Journey cool
you know we get so stuck on
figuring out what the perfect workout's
gonna be right have you ever done this
well I'm not going to do hit am I going
to do cardio how many weights are going
to do am I am I gonna am I gonna hurt
myself do I need to hire a trainer what
new equipment do I need to buy
you know we just get stuck in all this
planning mode instead of doing
just do anything just go for a walk
do five push-ups you know do a couple
burpees whatever whatever comes to mind
it doesn't matter what you do it's
matter that you're doing something
that's the big difference it doesn't
matter the specific action that you're
taking will matters that you're starting
to build some kind of momentum that
you're doing something
that's the most important thing because
if you
get up and you do something every day
you're going to find that you start
making some tremendous progress towards
things
and so two percent difference is to
teach yourself that you go from an idea
to some kind of immediate action that
we're doing something right away on it
we're not planning for 100 but we're
going for that first two percent the
next thing is just expect the suck at
the beginning
you know we expect to be great out of
the gate for some reason you expect your
idea to work you expect that you're
going to have the skills or who you
expect you're going to create something
amazing you won't just expect the socket
to start
it doesn't mean that you suck as a human
it just means that you don't have the
skill set yet and that's okay that's
normal and that's totally okay that's
fine
go back and watch my first video it was
pretty embarrassing go back and watch
anybody's first anything and it's and it
sucks
it's normal
so if you expect to be great
and then you try something and you can't
do it then you feel really bad about
yourself but if you expect it to suck
and then and then you're just anything
above complete terrible sucking
then you're good then you've won
and so
apply the two percent difference
and then just expect to suck to suck at
the start and then you keep going
So for anybody there who's afraid to
take action who you know you have these
big Ideas big goals Big Dreams big
things you want to do
but it just seems so Out Of Reach and it
seems impossible and it seems that you
can't do it and it's never going to work
you know and you're stuck in
overthinking
over planning over estimating over just
over over just stuck in your head
and it's crazy how quickly we can go
from being excited by something
to then almost instantly overwhelmed by
it
you know and so you need to have the big
dream you need to have the big goal that
that should get you out of bed and
excited it's like yes this is the change
I want to make in the world amazing and
at the same time you need a incredibly
small action plan just to get going
because you've got the great heart and
the big dream and the big mission the
only thing you're missing is momentum
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there the problem is people compare
themselves to others as a way to kick
themselves down you look at somebody
else who's done a lot more than you and
you say wow they're so much better than
me I can never do it